veux que vous fermez les yeux et pensez
à un souvenir qui vous rend heureux
et penser à un souvenir que vous
associer à votre jeunesse
maintenant penser au souvenir le plus
douloureux de votre fille à présent
ouvrez les yeux ce dispositif
extrait le véritable souvenir du cerveau
et nous leur transmet
la machine est incroyable la vérité non
filtrée et pure
c'est une perte terrible mais je voulais
juste vous dire à quel point je suis
désolé comment avez vous connu gordon il
m'a sauvé la vie
on l'a retrouvé mort dans son bureau
avec des impacts de balles dans les murs
des impacts aux blessures par balles il
travaillait avec beaucoup de personnes
perturbées il doit découvrir ce qui vous
est arrivé gobain
c'est le moins que je puisse faire
peut-être que je peux pas voir vous
souvenir et je peux voir les souvenirs
de ceux qui étaient près de vous qui
êtes vous je travaille pour sa veuve
je sais que vous l'avez vu sur la
cheminée mais je peux vous aider
oui allison allison est morte vous
pensez qu'il cache la vérité il y a des
gens qui vous cherche si l'automne un
homme a été assassiné
vous avez des choses plus importantes à
gérer
il ne faut pas qu'on sache que la
machine a disparu qu'est ce que vous
voulez je voulais vous poser quelques
questions sur gordon sortir ici notre
esprit oubliée des choses pour une
raison il y a des défauts à corriger
hallucinations perte de notion du temps
est ce que vous savez qui est cet homme
et l'automne a menti
parce que je pense savoir qui a tué leur
donne je serais très déçu si je
découvrais que vous manqué
il ya quelque chose que vous aimeriez
pouvoir oublier qui êtes-vous bcsa bcsa
aidez moi